a devilishly indulgent dessert nothing
beats a great cake a sort of a show-off
trophy for party food so I'm gonna make
the most amazing flourless chocolate
cake but with a twist first thing first
made the camera flatten the sugar never
stir a camel rule number one now keep
the pan nice and flat I'm gonna flavor
this Kara with a little bit of mint give
it a little chop sprinkle that into the
caramel don't get the caramel too dark
just nice and light a little teaspoon of
oil onto the tray and rub that in and
then pour out your camera it was making
a caramel sauce and I've put butter and
cream into the camera but I want this
nice minted brittle running through my
cake boss McConnell comes down on the
tray
I'm gonna make my cake first melt
good-quality dark chocolate in a
bain-marie heating it directly in the
pan would destroy the cocoa fats always
in a bowl over boiling water in a mixing
bowl sugar two whole eggs and three egg
yolks whisk until beautifully light and
creamy and the color changes to a light
yellow the more you mix the eggs in the
sugar a lighter texture in the center
the chocolate cake next melt some butter
into your warm dark chocolate and stir
puts that really nice Sheen velvety rich
and tasting amazing add that to your
sugar and your eggs mmm now give her a
really good mix and when you're making
flourless desserts it really is
important to work harder incorporating
air especially with the yolks and the
sugar that natural height needs to take
place at the beginning oh that looks
like the perfect chocolate ganache
then separate four egg whites into a
bowl
[Music]
now make sure you've got two-thirds of
the way there with your whites and then
just sprinkle in just sugar almost like
a meringue and a firmer you make these
now more will elevate your cake in the
oven
[Music]
that's what you call a stiff peak in
with the whites before I start mixing
that will get my camera just start
breaking up glass sheets of glass
beautiful save some of your minty candle
shards for decoration and use a rolling
pin to break up the rest into small
pieces sprinkle that in so as we start
to slice that chocolate cake you'll come
across that nice crunch take your cake
tin make sure it's lined with the
greaseproof paper on the bottom nicely
greased pour this in a few sharp taps on
a hard surface or rid your cake mixture
of any air pockets that could create
holes in your cake
sit that in the oven 180 after 35
minutes my chocolate mint cake is cooked
and whilst it cools down I can whip up a
peppermint cream topping add sifted
icing sugar and a few drops of
peppermint extract to double cream and
whisk until it's just holding its shape
spoon your minty cream on top of the
cake leaving a small ball of free to
make it easier to cut for a cake that
can't fail to attract attention at your
party
scatter over the remaining camel mint
shards
[Music]
start with a cookie dough simply
combined Muscovado sugar peanut butter
and butter until light and fluffy
then add your egg a splash of milk
vanilla seeds and beat again until
smooth
sit together salt baking powder and
flour a mix until thoroughly combined in
floured hands roll the cookie dough into
golf ball sizes flatten and create an
indent with your finger fill with half
jam and half peanut butter place the
cookies on a tray lined with baking
paper and bake in a preheated oven for
10 to 12 minutes cool before serving
[Music]
next a refreshing light dessert of lemon
and basil granita start by putting the
juice of 7 lemons and the zest of 1 into
a small pan with a sprintin of castor
sugar
[Music]
stir over a medium heat until the sugar
dissolves dilute your granita mix with a
little water
pour into a freezer proof container stir
in a good handful of chopped fresh basil
and place covered in the freezer for
three hours when the granita is frozen
around the edges
lightly break up the mixture with a fork
return to the freezer and repeat twice
until the granita is frozen with a
granular texture spoon into chilled
serving glasses garnish each with a
sprig of basil
[Music]
amazingly light and refreshing lemon and
basil granita
what we need to do first is to get these
peeled and sliced I got my pan on to get
nice and hot now let me give it a taste
of that they're incredibly acidic okay
and you need to cook them those
wonderful red apples you thought are
called braeburns
what their apples you know green ones
well they caught I'm not too sure what
the Queen was another word for your nun
grandma no no pink lady I know granny
smith apple that's right what we're
gonna do is cook the cooking apples and
the eating apples together I love the
combination of the tarts from the
crumbly cooking at all with the
sweetness of the Braeburn get the pan
nice in the hot let's sprinkle the
bottom of the pan with caster sugar
three or four nice slices of fresh
ginger and three little cinnamon sticks
I want you to remember that because
we're gonna look for them okay cuz once
we've used them and they've worked their
magic I need to pull them out see all
the sugar dissolving now we just let
that go a little bit darker okay and
then replace it very quick doesn't it
give that a nice little toss okay
cinnamon in ginger in so we're cooking
down the apples butter in gently cook
them to the apples soften then take off
eight
we go into that what's that coming out
dad so that is a little bit of the puree
I'll show how to do that in a minute
how many ginger for for ginger and three
three cinnamon out with a cinnamon
ginger changes I would take a spoon of
apples
but it smells so nice how nice is that
look see the color apples let's put
these in the fridge to get nice and cold
that's the compost sorted easy now
a simple creamy whip to crown the top
if you separate the egg whites into
their Fedele but egg whites are in quite
separate
[Music]
and I'll sprinkle sugar in and then you
turn up a space
[Applause]
now let's see if you've got a really
nice tip Peaks you lift them up that is
what I call a nice stiff peak well done
next in a separate Bowl whip double
cream until stiff
[Music]
so creating wit summers quicker nice
we're gonna put some delicious lemon
zest which will make the cream so much
better then sweeten it up with leftover
candy calm pop puree you mix that in
nice and carefully just like this apple
butterscotch now to make the cream even
lighter fold in those whipped egg whites
and sugar egg whites into the cream just
nicely fold that in so you bring your
glasses back out manage the glasses yep
good girl mmm silly we're off for a
treat open up the piping bag yeah
twist the end they could spoon this in
but I want to just give a nice look yes
like is it a nice patent lemon on top
back in the fridge you and I chef and a
prep the pears so if you peel our top
and toe into quarters pears go soft in
the oven very very quickly so we're
gonna put them on our charts we'll need
to leave them whole half or in quarter
what's that in there
ginger that's right a stem ginger so new
stem ginger and fresh ginger
next add your stem ginger a little of
the stem ginger syrup good girl and some
brown sugar to your quartered pears
and they're just great some fresh ginger
yeah so it's a bit of a um different one
to create this plus doesn't really come
through like the cheese not nobody that
little bit zesty now I've got some
lemons some lemon zest in there
right what is you doing out let's give
that a nice little mix now this is a
sweet pastry you can buy this stuff
where you make it so easy to do so give
me your finger
that's my center point and what you to
get the pears going around like that a
really nice circle it's difficult isn't
it cuz the pears keep on sliding all
over the place yeah egg wash the house
side and I'm gonna show you a little
trick so you lift that up acting like a
bit of a balloon that's right
[ __ ] this bear finger and the paste
reforms this nice little shelf a little
money back you going to do anything with
this bear pears
oh yeah you start building that up
anything
for the fresh ginger and there's a nice
little Chrysostom ginger let me go
around like we might go just on top
Phillies last job is to give out tart a
good dusting of icing sugar so that
caramelizes it and colors the pears
beautifully if it makes snow isn't it
now that glazes the pastry so the pastry
has this really nice shine on there as
well
finally the lemon on top put out there
180 and in chios
now pear tart has had 35 minutes in the
oven look at that baby
mmm would you like me to stop the sting
yes please
nice and gently all the way around good
girl buildups the yellows are gonna love
this it looks a bit like a snowy cake
doesn't it good job now very carefully
carry that to the table how nice is that
look